>> Cliff: All right. Good afternoon, everyone.
We're very
pleased to welcome Dr. Eric Isaacs from the
Argonne
National Laboratory. He's joining us for a
green at
Google presentation on energy policy and the
latest
breakthroughs and research to come out of
Argonne lab. In case you're
not familiar which all of us probably are
given our technical backgrounds, Argonne is
one of the
world's foremost centers physics and materials
research.
Also home of the famous white deer. Dr. Isaacs
is professor
of the University of Physics in Chicago and
he comes from storied career both with Bell
Labs and the
Center for Nanoscale Materials at Argonne.
And so he's
going to review for us today some of the basic
scientific
research and the game-changing energy breakthroughs
that
are happening right now at Argonne with the
goal of
finding revolutions in the energy sector,
whether that's
through Thorium or the batteries for the Chevy
volts.
I'll leave Eric to paint the picture. And
we'll have
time for some question and answer at the end
for the use
of the Q and A mic. But without further ado,
please join
me in welcoming Dr. Isaacs to Google.
>> [Applause]
>>Isaacs: Thank you Cliff. Also I want to
thank Cliff for
arranging this opportunity for me. So I would
like to
talk about energy as Cliff said, but in the
context of
really what it takes to let's call it change
the
game; something of course Google has done
in many ways
and certainly the automobile has done. It
changed the
game until the U.S.. So I'd like to talk about
what game
changing means. Of course you'll see my natural
tendency is to come out as a materals physicist,
condense matter physicist and talk a little
bit about the cool stuff behind the technology.
So I
thought I'd start off with analogy which is
of course
football. Whether or not you knew it I didn't
know this
until a few days ago. Football wasn't originally
prolated. It was
spherical and the game was invented effectively
so college men could
get out and practice sportsmanship, teambuilding.
They could practice
essentially military like activity without
getting too badly hurt,
without getting shot at. It turn out they
also got
brutalized a little bit. But there were real
game
changers and when I say game changer I don't
mean
winning a game like we see at Stanford University.
I
mean really changing the game. What changed
the game in
football was going from spherical to prolate.
All of
a sudden it we object from a game that was
kind of slow
maybe a little bit violent to one that was
extremely fast
and very violent. In fact, it got so violent
that in
1905, 18 players, college players died and
it cause president, a few
years later President Teddy Roosevelt to come
out and say
either change the game or stop playing it.
And the point
of saying that is sort of technilogical change
from spherical
ball to prolate ball which really did change
the game.
But also there was political intervention
when you talk about energy you can't
talk about one without the other. And you
can ask me
what's more important politics or let's call
it strategy
versus technology. And of course in the end,
the real change in the
game was now it's a multibillion dollar industry
for the
colleges. It's a multibillion dollar industry
in
general. It's no longer just a game for a
bunch of hacks to
play in a field somewhere in the back of a
school. It's a really a serious sport. So
that's one analogy for what changes. Let me
tell you a
little bit about one that's a little closer
to my heart,
which is change in technology. Many of you
will
recognize this. This just a charred couple
device. It's
one that this one is a reasonably recent one.
Just
the story of how this changed the game. This
is two guys
who actually two years ago won the Nobel prize.
Unfortunately the guy on the right here, George
Smith, just
died. But Smith and Boyle were working really
as individual researchers in a lab at
Bell Laboratories and they came up with an
idea for
memory. At the time they were competing for
something some of
you may remember here called bubble memory.
And there
was a decision at Bell Labs to cut this program,
which
was to make it solid state memory instead
of bubble
memory. And these guys figure, "What the hell
else can
we do with this if were not going to make
a shift register
and the memory to go with it." And they ended
up deciding "Hey, we have an idea. We can
use the optical properties of the material
and make it into a camera." Make
it into something that could image. And they
did. And
they actually saved their funding to do that.
This is
just an example of the first device. And it's
a cool
device. It is a shift register basically,
but it's
what's behind the charge couple device that's
the silicon. And here's
the first image to give you an idea what it
looked like. What's
really important though in the story about
changing the
game is that it did start off as this really
PI kind of
program, a couple of guys in a laboratory.
But very
quickly, who adopted it first? It wasn't a
big product
at first. It wasn't in your iPhone at first
of course.
It was actually adopted by the military. It
was
first adopted for spy satellites. This was
invented in
1969. By 1974, this device was orbiting the
earth taking
images of places like Afghanistan, a place
we still want
to take images of. This of course I just retrieved
yesterday off Google. And you guys know this
place very
well. But any of us now can use these charged
couple
devices in space and of course on your body
you have it
on your telephone. So that I call game changing.
Actually there were two early adopters. One
was the
military to do this kind of satellite imaging
down to the
meter now but of course there was the astrophysicists.
So there were scientists in the game even
in the mid-70s realizing
very quickly no longer do you need film, you
can do some
stuff much more clever by using charged couple
devices.
The point here was it was a big game and it
was changed.
It was changed by two guys at first who didn't
know they were
going to change the game. It was really just
two people
who ended up starting that revolution. But
it also took
many years, many years 5,6,7,10, 15
years to ultimately change the way many of
us live our lives. So
changing the game can take a long time. And
so, now I want
to talk about in that context energy technologies
and
thinking about how are we going to change
the game with
energy technologies? Just you know simple
fact is today
still we rely almost entirely on fossil fuels.
Solar
energy, which we all love to talk about. I
know you guys
have a solar automobile, is still less than
.1% of
energy production in this country or anywhere
in the
world. It's still a long way from being game
changing.
It's exciting to talk about, but it ain't
game changing
yet. So, of course, the challenge is obvious.
This is another image taken from the sky,
taken from earth. It's of course a time sequence
picture. And really the point of
showing this, two reasons to show it one just
to say
that we're using a tremendous amount of energy
on the
earth. The electricity associated with this
is about 15
terawatts. The U.S. consumes a quarter you
are of that, maybe a little more than a quarter
of that.
And you can see also a lot of dark regions
which are soon
to be developed. So the growth, not only do
we
consume a lot today, but by 2015, we're looking
at a
doubling in the consumption of electricity.
So this huge
growth. And of course that's electricity which
today
across the world is mostly generated by fossil
fuels. So
that means we're also producing carbon. Many
of you have
seen diagrams, like this a a famous wedge
diagram. Today we're
spewing about 30 gigatons of carbon into the
atmosphere. What
does that mean? Thirty gigatons naturally
occurring carbon
in the atmosphere is about 700 gigatons. So
it's about 5% a year. In 20 years we're
doubling the amount of carbon. Unless it's
absorbed or
unless the earth is adapting. So we don't
know what's going to happen. This is the chart
that
the International Energy Agency where they
project
out on current conditions. So business as
usual. And you can see
that essentially there's growth in the carbon
production
roughly speaking with the growth of electricity
consumption because there's a direct growth.
What's interesting about this is the IEA also
suggests
that there are ways we can start thinking
about bringing
this curve down. Business as usual I would
argue is
unacceptable. But one could argue there's
a lot of
things you could do and the first and easiest
thing is energy
efficiency. It doesn't sound very glamourous,
very sexy but even in this
country over half of the energy we use is
wasted as heat.
These lights you have here, probably more
efficient than most, but 20% of the electricity
in this country is used for lightbulbs and
lighting. And of that more than half of it
is wasted
simply as heat. So there's a lot waste. So
if you can
imagine solid state lighting, etcetera, you
all hear about, you do a tremendous amount
just in
suppressing the amount of carbon we produce.
And there's other things here, renewables,
and I'll
focus on a few of these as I go forward. Just
as a
summary, there are many things and you guys
are all
familiar with the types of alternative energies
here:
wind, solar. Again solar is a tiny piece of
what we
produce today. Wind's a little bit larger
than solar.
It's a few percent, but not much larger. We
of course
still have nuclear in this country. Twenty
percent of our
power is nuclear. What are we going to do
with those?
And of course if you're going to do things
like biofuels
or continue to use fossil fuels thinking about
carbon
sequestration is critical. But one of my main
points here is that every one of these is
not a done deal
yet. None of these are major adoption. Except
for
nuclear, none of these have been adopted in
a major way
into our system. What makes the game change
with any of
these alternative energies? We talk about
them; we'd love to see them happen but they're
far away from happening yet. So one of the
places where we're thinking
a lot about this and Cliff introduced me as
being the
director of Argonne National Labs. I'm not
going to
spend a lot of time talking about national
labs, but I
just want to tell you how we're different
from academia
and how we're different from industry in what
when he do.
But there's a huge difference in the kind
of research we do.
It's mission-driven. So it looks a lot more
like a
Google or an AT&T doing Bell Labs or like
an IBM doing Yorktown Heights doing research,
fundamental research but with the idea maybe
not tomorrow maybe not in 5 years but 20 years
down the road
we want to make that game change. We want
to be able to
innovate, whether it's in nuclear, whether
it's in solar,
whether it's in biofuels we want to make the
discoveries, the fundamental
discoveries that will impact. And that's what
I mean by
mission-driven. And, of course, at Argonne
we have over a thousand Ph.D.
researchers, smaller than probably the number
of
engineers that you have here. But still all
working in force
in science to deliver that mission. We do
a lot of cross-discipline work.
So another thing that distinguishes us from
for example
University is we aren't PI, singly, only PI
driven. Like you guys we have
a lot of meeting rooms, we have a lot of people
working together. So we
have material scientists working with computer
scientists
working with chemists and working with engineers
because
we also have a lot of engineering to try to
solve some of
these problems. It's somewhat different. There's
a
different imperative at a place like Argonne
than there is say at a
University. We have major facilities and I'll
come back
to this later. Kinds of facilities we have
include
synchrotrons. Major accelerators that generate,
that allow us to study
materials and chemistries at the nano scale
that you
don't have anywhere else. They're open user
facilities. You
have one down the road at Stanford which you
can go and
you can use a free electron laser to do material
science for
example with very, very, very high resolution.
And then we have
research networks. So one of the things we're
looking to
do, one of the reasons I'm happy to be here
today is to
talk about our networks. We work very hard
and not
in an insular way. We're working hard with
industry and we work
hard certainly with regional efforts. But
our
collaborations. We have people come into the
lab from
all around the country and internationally
as well. So
we have a very large set of networks that
we rely onto
solve some of these bigger problems. So we
could
probably sit here all day and brainstorm and
say, "what
would be game changers in energy? These are
a list of a few that I put
down last night, room temperatures superconductors.
I'll come back to this. If we had a metal
that conducted
electricity without any loss at room temperature,
you'd
have a perfect transmission line for example,
and I'll come back to this one. If you could
create a
one penny per mile battery. Today we're talking
about
something that's almost 100 times more expensive.
So that's why
the Volt is a great automobile, but it's got
a 15
kilowatt battery and that car costs 15,000
dollars. It's
a large fraction of the cost of the car. It's
also a large
fraction of the weight of the car. So one
cent per mile
battery is a game changer. Five cent a kilowatt
solar,
today its cheapest is 20 cents and that's
subsidized. So
it's really 50 cents to a dollar per kilowatt
hour.
Compared to for example what I pay at Argonne
for
electricity to power my big machines. I pay
5 cents a
kilowatt hour so it's got to be fully adopted
unless
you want to subsidize it which is something
California
has tried. You really have to get to make
something
transformational, you have to be at the 5
cent level.
The Internet-like power grid people talk about
all the time if
you have solar and wind and nuclear. Nuclear
is a
constant. Solar is very variable. Wind is
very variable. You really like to manage
the country's energy grid like you manage
the Internet.
The country is broken into three grids. There's
the west
grid, east grid and then there's Texas believe
it or not.
But even within those grids, it's broken up.
If you go
to the southern part of Illinois and look
over the border
of Kentucky, you'll see a 110 volt line running
across
someone's backyard to another backyard. You
can't
possibly share power. And in fact, that means
in
Illinois where we have a lot of nuclear, we
have a glut
of power. That's why I can pay so little for
it and why here
you're paying more than I'm paying. You're
getting it
from a little bit farther away. The point
is if you could manage the grid like you
do the Internet, you could have a modern grid
and you
could do all, you could add all these renewables
to it.
And the last I mentioned here we can debate,
but fuels.
This is sort of fuels from sunlight. It's
actually a
project that CalTech and Berkeley are working
very hard on now.
It's a great idea. The idea we want to mimic
a photosynthesis. We want to take CO2, H2O,
simple,
very simple molecules and with a photon from
the sun
produce alcohols; sugars, alcohols, ultimately
even sophisticated drop in
biofuels like biodiesel. If you can do that
at scale you'd
have something important. And we can debate
whether you
can do that or not. So what I thought I would
do is just
start with an example of some of the stuff
we do. But I
think also reflects on what I think as game
changing;
trying to change the game anyway. And that's
really
thinking about 21st century transportation.
The U.S.
just for some more numbers, the U.S. consumes
20 million
barrels of oil a day. Ok? If you could wean
all of our
transportation from using petroleum, using
gasoline to
electrifying it meaning you go from filling
a gas tank
to powering your vehicle with a cord. We've
estimated, and these are numbers we'll talk
about that in a minute, that you'd reduce
the consumption of oil by a third.
That's about 7 million barrels a day. That's
a huge
change. So if you're talking about energy
independence,
that's a good move. It's a good thing to do.
At the same time because so much of
the carbon produced comes from automobiles,
you save
about 25% of the carbon we produce. So both
really good things. We did this. We actually
have what
we call life cycle analysis at Argonne. We
did this for
the country. We've also done it for China.
So if we did it
for the United States, we reduce the carbon
footprint by
25%. You could ask the same thing about China.
This is an interesting point. If you take
China and ask,
well let's say if we electrify and they have
goals
now to reach 10 million by 2025. Tell me an
electric vehicle ask does that reduce the
carbon footprint? The answer is no. It turns
out
because China is 80% coal powered plants.
Just by
shifting the power generation back to the
power plants,
you can say, "oh," you assume because you
have a battery
operated car, you're doing better. You don't.
In this country, we do because 20% of our
electricity is nuclear.
There's a large fraction that's natural gas,
10% is natural gas. There is a
lot of coal. There is a lot of fossil fuel
in there.
But the point is that you have to ask the
question.
It's a systemic question at the system level.
And if you
don't ask that question you can't just assume
well, doing
electric cars is a good thing. Well we think
it's a good
thing because in the U.S. we could have a
significant
impact on energy independence and on carbon
footprint.
What is one of the major challenges, and this
is where Argonne
spends a lot of its time, is how to store
energy in compact
spaces? This is really a chart to give just
meant to give you a sense of
where we are today and where we need to be.
This is a funny chart, theoretical versus
practical specific
energies. Specific energies is just the amount
of energy I can pack per
kilogram of battery, okay? So just as a reference
I have
octane gasoline. Gasoline we're way far away
from
gasoline today, okay? And gasoline so if I
want to
power a car 400 miles, right? If I want to
move a car
400 miles on a single charge for example with
an electric
car. Today because I'm using lithium ion at
best, I
need a battery that's ten times the mass of
gasoline that
I put in my tank. So that's why, if you look
at the
Chevy Volt, which I showed in the last slide.
If you
look at the battery in the Chevy Volt, it's
this massive
thing underneath the car that weighs actually
more than 500 pounds and that
gets you 40 miles. If you want a factor of
ten, the battery has to be ten times
bigger and this is the reason: you just can't
get
enough energy per kilogram. So what we're
doing is
thinking about what's next. So batteries are
here,
lithium ion and all of the things you hear
in the
press about lithium ion. If we do great stuff
and we
are going to do great stuff we get a factor
of two in
energy density. The dot is actually spherical.
And
we're sort of at the bottom of that red oval.
So we get
a factor of two if we push really hard which
means that
the technology has to change. You can't use
lithium ion
to do what you really want to do, Americans
in
particular. China, if you're driving around
Beijing, you
might get away with a 40 mile vehicle but
in this
country, California, certainly in the Midwest
you're
not going to get away with a 50 mile vehicle
won't do it.
You need a 400 mile vehicle. To do that, you
need to go
to these brand new technologies which I'll
talk about in
a minute. Lithium Air, Lithium Sulfur a new
way to
think about a battery. It's actually a battery
that
breathes oxygen and is able to get much higher
densities.
There is by the way from a physicist's point
of view and I'm a physicist, a lot of room
at the top. Even if
I look at octane. Hydrogen bonds and octane
are what
store the energy. When we burn them that's
what we
break. You get a lot of energy out of octane.
But
octane isn't the theoretical limit. The theoretical
limit
on paper is about a factor of 100 greater
than todays batteries
and a factor of ten greater than even the
dream I have up
here to replace gasoline. And it's actually
getting down
to quantum devices which I won't talk about,
but from a
physicist's point of view there's a lot of
room, a lot of
head room, meaning a lot of cool research
which is what
we're about. I just wanted to point that out.
So here's just an example of a future battery.
We haven't built it yet. I would call this
a known unknown. Because we don't know how
to
do it yet, but we know if we could build this
kind of
battery, we could get to the energy densities
that could
get you that 400 mile vehicle. I won't get
through the
details but it involves a different way to
think about batteries. Batteries always look
this way, there's a
cathode and anode. And the anode and cathode
are
differently charged. And lithium in a lithium
battery
shuttle back and forth usually through a liquid.
When
you charge it, the lithium go over to this
cathode. And
when you discharge it, the lithium filters
back into the
anode. When you charge it back up like in
a lithium
battery, you drive the lithium back over into
the cathode
side. And that's how battery cycles. It's
very simple.
And this is an advanced idea that we're working
on which
involves different kinds of cathodes and anodes.
But
fundamentally it breathes. And it breathes
because it
takes the lithium ion and combines it with
oxygen and
makes lithium peroxide. The challenge there
it's
great because actually you get a lot of energy
out of
that bond. So you can get it out of that battery.
But
the problem is breaking it. That's why we
need catalysts
to break lithium oxide and oxide bonds. But
if you made
a battery like this, the reason it's called
is because it
actually breathes. The oxygen comes in, burns
the
lithium, and goes out again. You have to be
able to have
it go out again. By the way, the problem,
that's a chemistry problem, breaking lithium
oxide. It's the same chemistry problem
or similar to the one I need to make CO2,
H2O and
sunlight into sugar. So there's a lot of commonality
in
fundamental science we have to solve to make
these
exciting things happen. So this will give
you the energy
density. Just one other example is about nano
science. I know you guys
have heard about nano science. This is just
a nano
science example. This is not for energy density
although
it gets high energy density. Using nano, you
can
actually do fast charging. So one of the other
problems
when you think about range anxiety is, if
it takes eight
hours to charge your car and it can only go
30 miles,
what do you do when you get to work and how
do you get
home? We have to think very differently about
how to
structure the batteries. And this is a way
to think
about it. You have to have a lot of porous
material that are dense. And it turns out
you can use a lot of things like this, which
is using a patterned array of these
titanium oxide tubes. The tubes are hollowed.
The
lithium can get in and out. It can do all
kinds of
things. So you can actually do clever things
and we're
starting to think about using nano technology
also to
drive the speed and the density. So you're
combining
these things. So this is just one example.
I'm talking
about energy density, I'm talking about speed
of charging. But in the end,
this is what we want. It's green. It's got
everything
we want. Creating an artificial leaf would
really be a dream.
Today when you look at a leaf, this is green.
As my
Friend, Nate Lewis at CalTech would tell you,
if a leaf were really
efficient at absorbing sunlight, it would
be black. The
fact is that a leaf is not very efficient
at taking
sunlight and converting it to sugars which
provide it
with life. It's not efficient because it doesn't
need to
be. It's really interested in reproduction.
It's not
interested in producing at scale lots of material
lots
of ethanol that we would like to have. So
we're
working. Lots of people are working on the
idea of
really taking a leaf. But there are many other
problems
like this. But taking a leaf and making fuels.
Learning
how it works. Learning how proteins work etcetera.
So this
is a very interesting problem, it's yet to
be solved.
One other point I'll make is just in case
you have a
conversation at a cocktail party about biofuels
because
you all hear about it. I want to make one
point. The
average solar influx or flux on the surface
of the earth is about
200 watts per square meter. So if you take
a square
meter and you ask how much sunlight do you
get, you get
four or five light bulbs, good light bulbs.
And that's actually a lot. It
turns out that, if I want all the electricity
the U.S.
uses, it's about three terawatts. If I take
the state of
Kansas, there's no one from Kansas here I
hope. I took the
state of Kansas and I plastered it with solar
photovoltaics, I'd have enough electricity
for the
entire country if I converted it roughly 50%
with efficiency. The problem with
the leaf and even all the biofuels you hear
about, if it
take that same meter and say I grow grass
and I want to
convert that grass to biofuels, like to swtichgrass
or cellulosic materials. And I want to convert
that to fuel and then burn that. How much
energy do I
get? Remember, this thing is only about 0.1%
efficient at converting that energy. So I'm
only using
about .1% of that 200 watts per meter squared.
So you ask me as physicist, I'd say you're
much better
off with photovoltaics than biofuels. The
problem with
photovoltaics of course is that you have to
store the power. It's
automatically used. And that gets back to
the smart
grid. If you can bring it into the grid right
away
either by storing it in big batteries or actually
using power generated
in southern California using it in places
like Nevada --
or maybe Nevada has their own, or maybe sending
it up to Seattle.
That would be a dream. If you look at solar,
I think in
the end its the answer but we're far away
from it
because we just don't have the solutions yet.
So now I
want to talk a little bit about game changing.
This is where I get
into my perspective as a condensed matter
materials physicist where
the game change and the technology begins.
Everything
I've talked about whether it's a leaf or it's
a battery
involves fundamental materials, new materials.
And I
just showed you the CCD really just involved
silicon. So
let me start off by reminding you what really
started the
revolution everyone in this room lives on
which is, of
course, Moore's Law for Silicon Technology.
The idea that
we all know Moore's law, right? Doubling every
few years of the density of chips. And that
keeps going on and on.
And that's great. But you got to understand
that, before
we even got to the first 1k of processor or
the, you
know, the 404. I personally remember the 886.
I
remember the first in college, that was what
I had. But
that's been a metronome only because we understood
silicon at its deepest level. We understood
silicon way
back even before 1960 we understood what silicon
was
like. We understood its electronic properties,
we
understand its optical properties, and we
understood its
very fundamental science. So we were able
to then with great
predictability take the risk of building a
billion dollar
manufacturing plant. Intel could do it and
easily just
say we'll invest the billion because we know
where we're
going to be in ten years. We know exactly
where we're going to be. Moore's law is of
course not a
law, it's a conjecture. But the fact is that
we knew a lot about
the material. The problem with most the other
things I've
been talking about, all the energies stuff,
we don't know what the answer is. The
materials are more complicated than silicon,
the systems
are much more complicated than a transistor
built on
silicon. And so, what I have on this little
patch, I applogize, it's pretty
cryptic. It shows a road map for batteries.
We're right down
here today. We're with lithium metal oxide
anodes and
graphite anodes, so it would be an anode and
a cathode. And this shows you by the time
you get
out to about 2019, we don't even know what
kinds of
anodes you're going to get based on the kinds
of energy densities
that road map projects. So I told you we're
have to get up toward gasoline. We're talking
about
2019 and 2021 getting closer to gasoline.
But we don't
even know what the materials are going to
be. So if you
want me to go out and say I have an answer
for you, it's
going to be very hard for anyone to, a company
to say,
"fine we'll build a manufacturing plant at
100 million
dollars before we even know the materials."
So the real
challenge today in energy at the very fundamental
level
is understanding the materials we have. Understanding
how to make and how to predict materials that
we can use
to do the kinds of things I've been talking
about. To
generate a battery that's got 400 miles behind
it. And
so, the way we know how to do that. In fact,
we know.
This is actually I just got this two days
ago. I don't
know if you guys know Bob Laughlin. He's a
college up at Stanford University. He won
a Nobel Prize
for something called the fractional quantum
hall effect but he's a condensed matter physicist.
This equation here, H, which is called the
Hamiltonian is
really the equation of everything. If I could
solve this
equation, I would know everything I need to
know about a
material. He just wrote this down on paper
before he
gave his Nobel lecture. I'm not going to solve
this
equation for you. I know solving equations
is always
risky at giving a talk. I'm just showing it
to tell you, that in
principle, I can I write down an equation
that will tell me everything about the electrons
and atoms in any solid including in your body.
So the proteins in
your body, life itself. And you can see the
list he
made. If we could solve this equation, then
we would
know everything from how to put together an
economist
which he said as a joke all the way back to
Ebola virus, glass, wood
and batteries. You could do everything. All
this is the first two terms, the first term
is just the kinetic
energy of electrons, the second is kinetic
energy of
nuclei. The third term is the interaction
between the
electrons and the nuclei. And the fourth and
fifth
terms are the interactions between the electrons
respectively
and nuclei respectively. If you have that,
you have
everything in a solid: whether it's a protein,
protein
in a leaf that's doing catalysis or whether
it's an Ebola
virus, you know everything about that material.
The problem is we just can't solve this equation.
We can't solve it for silicon. So, for silicon,
if you
ask what are its optical properties, this
won't help give
you that answer, because you can't solve this
equation.
And the reason you can't solve it is because
it's a very
Complicated, many-bodied problem. But things
are starting
to change and that's one of the reasons I
wanted to, I'm excited about it. Computing
is actually
slowly becoming, computing has always been
important
for us because we model stuff. You go out
and you
measure something and you model stuff. So
physicists and
chemists and scientists you guys take data
and you model
it. It's always been possible to model. But
what we
haven't ever been able to model are the properties
of
materials because the complexity of that simple-looking
equation. But we're actually really at a transition
point in
and out. We're at a petaflop of computing
ability. So
we're just starting to taste the ability to
do things
that we never were able to do before. We're
not there
yet, but we're close to it. So this is the
K computer. You guys may have heard they just
pulled last week as the fastest computer in
the world.
For the last three computers, they haven't
been here.
They've been overseas unfortunately, two in
China, sorry, one in China and two
in Japan K computer. It's a 10 petaflop machine.
And of course
what we're pushing towards is the exit scale.
At 10
petaflops we can start thinking about taking
the equation
and actually modeling real materials. Understanding
the
properties of those real materials ultimately
to predict the
properties of materials. So I might be able
to tell a
manufacturer one day "I'll tell you exactly
what
materials you can build. If you want to build
a battery
that's got a 400 mile range here are the materials
you
need." So it's what I call materials by design,
and I'll come back to that. But
there's some challenges here. First you're
still solving a
many-bodied problem. And when you talk about
these parallel computers, there
are problems you can solve today especially
local
problems like hydrodynamics. So for example,
one of the
things we're using these major computers for
now Boeing
uses them for example to eliminate wind tunnels.
You can
do things like hydrodynamics. You can do wind
dynamics. So you can
actually design an airplane. In fact the 787
is entirely
designed using computers like this at Boeing.
That's
great. But still those are fairly local problems.
When
you get to problems like climate, which is
very
multiscale and very complex, or a solid -- take
just a
hunk of material like lithium oxide. We still
can't do
it with this computer. So that's one challenge.
We're
still working on it. We're getting closer.
The other
thing is you know these computers are pretty
energy
intensive. So there's actually buried underneath
these fast
computers is actually the energy challenge.
Physicists
always thought of the challenge with computing
as being
the transistor itself. And as you get to higher
and
higher densities of chips, you get to fewer
and fewer
electrons per switch. And when you get down
to one
electron per switch it's quantum mechanical.
So you
switch it and it's either on or off. That's
not good
enough. So that's the problem we thought was
the
problem. The real problem today is heat. Each
of those
transistors leaks. Each of those transistors
have leakage
current. Turns out this machine well, a one
petaflop
machine is about a megawatt of power. A 10
machine is about three to four megawatts of
power. And
we want to go to an exit scale 1,000 times
faster. So
we're talking about a small nuclear power
plant to power
an exit scale computer. So we think these
are solveableproblems.
But we have problems to solve within the computers
Themselves which is pretty cool. So let me
finish by
saying on this particular topic which is to
say we are
making inroads on being able to take that
kind of machine
and compute properties and predict properties,
right?
Which for the first time really, ever, in
the last few years.
Because once we get to a petaflop, we can
take that
equation and solve it on a computer. It's
hard to solve
analytically, but you could solve it on a
computer. And
that's what we're starting to be able to do.
And this is just
some work done by Gerd Cedar from MIT; we
work closely with him. And he's doing things
like taking that Hamiltonian complicated somewhat
complicated equation and
solving it on a computer. And what we're able
to do now
is, instead of trying lots and lots of Edisonian
approaches to materials and that's what we
do with
batteries, for example. We try intelligently.
We use high power
thinking as well as high power computing.
But this kind
of computing will actually allow you to start
narrowing
down the kinds of materials. And in fact,
Gerd just worked on
Lithium ion batteries and predicted two new
materials
which have been pretty good. So we're starting
to be able to do it but we're probably a few
years off from being able to
solve the major problems. And one of the reasons
just to
give you a reason why it's so hard not to
show you a
fancy physics equation. This is just a material
you may
have heard of high temperature superconductor.
And
its constituents are Yttrium, Barium and Copper,
which if
you just pick up are normal boring metals.
But, if you
put them together in a very interesting form
which
essentially is made up of planes of copper
and oxygens. I have to add oxygen, I don't
have it up there.
And then separate those planes basically by
Barium and
Yttrium, you end up with things that superconduct.
And I
mentioned superconductivity before as one
of those things I
mentioned before as being those things that
could really
transform the grid for example. So we could
never
predicted this material. It was a bunch of
guys in a
laboratory just like the first two in the
CCD who were
playing around with materials and thought
they had
something cool and when they discovered
superconductivity, it was just a eureka moment.
They
never thought they would get it. They got
it. And in
fact, this problem is still not solved. Physicists
still
don't understand why the stuff superconducts
at 90. We now
have one at about 130 degree kelvin, even.
So it's still a challenge, these fundamental
materials problems. We can't predict certainly
can't predict how to make this
material. Nobody could have. But even now
we don't understand in hindsight how this
material was made. But I'll
come back to the energy grid. If we could
solve the
problem and generate 90 degree superconductor
is great
because it works at liquid nitrogen temperature.
So you
could still use it. Liquid nitrogen is not
so expensive.
So out in Long Island, this is the Long Island
Power
Authority, used to be called LILCO for those
of you that
know New York.
Actually it took three superconducting cables
with a
carrying capacity of 500 megawatts. That's
huge. That's
about as much power as a major power station
generates. In just these three cables, their
able to generate and transmit that kind of
power. So this is just a test bed.
The reason you see these fat pipes is that
they have to drive
liquid nitrogen through them. But one day
you could image having these thing across
the grid, replacing old copper with things
like
this that really could transform the grid
with losses.
So there's one more point I wanted to make.
I
wouldn't call it a sour point but it really
is a struggle
for this kind of activity material science.
I hope
I'm getting across the point that material
science is really at
the heart of all these energy technologies.
Whether it's chemistry like photolysis like
in plants or whether it's new
materials like in batteries or super conductors.
This is
a chart which only goes to 2007 but it hasn't
changed out to 2010 or 2011. Which kind of
says the
state of the U.S. is. And this is just, it's
done in a
certain way. It's by measuring publications,
percentage of publications since 1992.
And you see the United States has fallen in
fact, we're
now well behind China on production just of
knowledge.
Just basic knowledge. The knowledge that feeds
this kind
of important technology. We're just not doing
as much
anymore. These are just examples. This is
an example
within a particular kind of field material
synthesis.
But the point is we're not doing as much.
I sort of
attribute that to two things. One is you guys.
Because a lot of kids want to do
co-development, they want to do algorithms.
They want to do apps. They
want to do fun stuff that you guys allow them
to do. And
that's great, because we're attracting a lot
of bright
early people. I look out at the audience and
a lot of early career people here and that's
good. There's a lot of people being turned
away.
There's another reason too and the reason
is that the big labs
like Bell Labs and IBM no longer do this stuff
at all.
The U.S. used to have these big labs embedded
in
Companies much like you do, you're a vertically
integrated
company. You go all the way up to the applications
from
very basic code development. We don't have
that in the
United States anymore so we don't have the
vertically
integrated companies that drive mission. And
it's one of
the things that the DOE labs are trying to
fill the hole. So
let me sort of wrap things up a little bit
here. So come
back to this concept of how does it game change?
And
maybe some of you have seen this kind of chart
before.
This is actually from the New York Times.
They haven't
done it recently so it's a little outdated.
But it give
you a sense of what adoption of new energy
or just
technology in general look like everything
from the
telephone which took 50, 80 years to adopt
to
Internet which was adopted very quickly. The
trend is as you get
closer and closer to modern technologies,
things go
faster and faster. The question is what will
energy
technologies look like? It's my contention
that we
believe we can make it go very fast, but there
are a lot
of hurdles to go over to get there. There's
a lot of
material problems to solve. There could be
eureka
moments, but in the end, we can't rely on
eureka moments.
It really involves critical mass of people
like you guys
sitting around thinking through the problems
much like
Boyle and Smith did back in the late 60s.
And my concern
on this chart ask do we have the people sitting
this part
of the curve really thinking through the materials
problems, the chemistry problems -- that we
address.
It used to be we did this kind of stuff at
a place like Bell Labs. I
spent 15 years here. I don't know if anyone
of you have
ever been in Bell Labs. It's where C programming
language was invented. That was invented in
this wing here on the left. The wing on the
right. So the
left wing just so you know it wasn't entirely
integrated.
The left wing was where all code developers
and software and
guys like Richie sat. The right-hand side
was where all
the physical scientists where I was. Way before
my time
you could walk down that hall, called the
infinite corridor and you walk down the hall
and there's a little
plaque. It's where the transistor was invented.
That kind of place doesn't exist in material
science
anymore. It doesn't exist in chemistry. It
doesn't
exist in this fundamental technology developments
in many ways
anymore aside from places like this in this
country. And
so, we're trying to recreate that. So once
we develop
these things here we believe that we're starting
to bring
National Labs into play in a very big way.
This is a
picture of my lab. There are 17 of us in National
Lab.
There's one in Stanford, Berkeley, we have
one outside of
Chicago associated with the University of
Chicago. This
is just one of the devices we use to do discovery
science. This is a synchrotron which is about
a kilometer around. Electrons whiz around
at the speed of light and they generate x-rays
and we use
those x-rays to study things like new materials
for cathodes like catalytic processes.
This is a nano science building here where
I showed you that
battery of nano tubes that was developed there.
So we
provide these tools and we're trying to regenerate
that
ecosystem where we vertically integrate where
we have
people doing fundamental science but also
in other places
besides this at the laboratory. See Chicago
in the
background if you look carefully. The other
places in
the laboratory, which is about 1500 acres,
we have people who are doing engineering
working closely with companies like General
Motors. Working closely
with companies like Ford and Mitsubishi to
try to solve some of those
challenging problems. And of course here at
Google is
where we're changing the world too. Really
game
changing. The challenge I had with Google,
of course,
Google X now we've read about in the New York
Times.
Maybe you guys can tell me, this is the best
you can do if you Google Google X. I assume
when you're doing at Google X is also game
changing and
maybe you can tell me what's going on. If
you Google
Google X you get this but that's also where
the game is changing. What
the Times said if you put people in different
disciplines
who aren't doing the same things together
and just let
them have fun, in other words let them really
try new things.
Let them try to solve the problem of the battery.
Just
let them go do it. Give them as much latitude
as they
want, or let them go solve the problem of
solar
energy or photovoltaics. And that's really
important. And this is my last slide. Just
to repeat again. This is
just up the road from you. This is at SLAC
National
Accelerator Lab which is if you is like Argonne.
We are
run by the University of Chicago. This is
run by
Stanford University and what you see here
is the future. You can't
tell it, it's just a time lapse photo at night,
is the next generation of sources for xrays.
I showed you this big ring which was a Synchrotron.
This which you can't see because it's
buried beneath some of these buildings which
is a Linac about 3
kilometers long and it's the world's first
X-ray laser.
So you remember back in the early 60s when
the laser was
invented which was also at Bell Labrotoriess
and Columbia
University, it changed the world. Lasers changed
the way we communicate, they changed everything.
That was a game changer. This was a new type
of lasers but instead of
visible light like the red light in the pointers
or green lights in the pointers, this is actually
using very, very high
energy light called X-rays. And its capabilities
are
unbelievably dramatic. This is just up the
road from you
guys. This is the kind of thing that will
change the
game one day but hasn't done it yet. So I
think I'll
stop there and open it up for any questions.
>> [Applause]
>> Male #1: So one of your points there was
that photovoltaics had
to get down to five cents to be competitive.
But they're
being competitive within an industry that's
externalized a
lot of its costs. So there's another way to
change the
game.
>>Isaacs: I would agree with you actually.
My public statement is
that. I fully agree with you. If you look,
this
country is free market economy. Everything
has to be
driven by free market. But I think you hit
on an important point.
Energy is anything but free market. It's run
by two
groups utilities, which are regulated like
crazy. So
for example, your utilities can't raise the
rates by a
nickel to put in big solar because they are
more
expensive, but they can't. If they did, they
would create the market.
So that's one way you could do it. And then
of course,
it's petroleum and that's a cartel. So we
have no control
over the cartel, mostly in the Middle East.
In fact, I was asked,
I was on a panel about a month ago with the
Electric Chemical Society and I was asked,
it was a great question, in the end what is
really the challenge to getting these
energy technologies out? Is it policy or is
it
technology? And three years ago before I became
director
of the lab, I easily would have said, "I'm
a physicist;
it's technology. We got to invent new technology."
Today I would say a lot of it is policy. We
don't have a coherent energy policy in this
country.
China does. So they are spending more, even
in China, they're spending more per
kilowatt than I told you here. But there's
policy to level
the playing field. And that's I think your
point. It
isn't a level playing field for a small company
trying to do
solar versus the utilities. I don't think
the utilities
are intentionally keeping out solar. It's
just they have
to deliver power to you at a cost. They can't
lose
money. So they have to do what they have to
do. So I
agree with you. That is probably one of the
major issues
around adopting these technologies. It's a
little
different than the IT revolution in the sense
there
wasn't anything competing, right? Now of course
there is
something competing. It's called oil.
>>Male #2: So I was wondering if you'd also
talk about the role
of public perception in energy game changers
too. I'm
thinking of like the move, the potential of
something
like thorium but then people when they think
of nuclear
power they think meltdowns, Chernobyl and
Japan. So can education change the game too?
>> Isaacs: Yeah, actually that's a very good
question. In fact, I just wrote an
article in the Huffington Post about this
exact problem.
The public perception about energy in general
is not very
well defined because we haven't done a good
job of
talking about it. You bring up nuclear and
that's the
hottest button there is out there. That always
brings out the
best and worst of people out there. People
are either
very afraid of it because it's nuclear; don't
understand
it. They see the risks. Nuclear by the way
is safer
than coal. More people die of rearing coal
than they ever will
of nuclear power. So educating people about
those risks, I mean it's only fair that the
public gets to
decide the risk/cost benefit sort of analysis.
But in
the end we don't have the right information
out there.
So one of the things we've been pushing for
at the lab
and I think all over the country is a much
clearer education
about what these different technologies mean,
what they really cost,
for example what their impact on the environment
really is. What nuclear's real impact
is is a very good question. It's really easy
to dig coal
out of the ground. But look at how many people
die in
coal mines every year. It sounds easy, but
it's really
not. And we don't hear those stories. But
you'll hear about, Fukushima was a
terrible accident, but we don't know yet the
full extent
of that accident, but even that you could
argue worked
right for what it was, it worked okay. And
not many
people died. So there is a real issue about
education
which we don't really think about. So I would
advocate
that we think about it in high schools in
K through 12 and we
think about incorporating it much more. And
we see that.
My kids 13-year-old and a 17-year-old. They
see more of it in
their chemistry classes. But it really needs
to be a national
effort educate people on at least so they
can understand the
risks involved with each of these technologies.
>> Male #3: Speaking of education. I do a
lot of education work.
And you mention Google is people are attracted
to it
because we attract a lot of programmers, developers,
people who want to develop apps. And the critical
part
of that is the barrier of entry is very low
when it comes to doing
computer programming. My 8-year-old cousin
is writing
his first computer program right now. Material
science
is a little different. Is there any way to
really bring
material science into a classroom or create
small hands-on kits that really get people
involved?
>> Isaacs: You know, when I grew up, everyone
had chemistry kits.
My kids never had a chemistry kit. I probably
could have
bought them one. [chuckle] But there's risks.
There you go, no.
>> Male #3: You can't buy one anymore.
>>Issacs: You can't buy one anymore, okay.
So I think basically it's
not just because it's easy, there is a lower
barrier. It's also because we don't
talk about it. But also frankly industry isn't
here
anymore. I have graduate students in physics.
You see
that the culture in physics has changed since
I was a grad
student at MIT many years ago. Then people
were going
into it partially to be physicists. But also
they
realized they could go to Intel they could
go to IBM, they could go to Bell Labs. I
went to Bell Labs. That was my dream since
I was 15, 17
whatever. Part of it was just me because I
had that but I think a lot of
people don't hear about these things so much
anymore.
All we hear about are apps. That's not a bad
thing. You
know, I look at University of Chicago. Has
this great
new entrepreneurial center built by actually
Michael
Polsky. Michael Polsky is a wind entrepreneur.
He actually
built wind companies out of Chicago. He's
made a fair
amount of money doing it. And he contributed
some money
to the University of Chicago. In their first
five years or four years of
existence, they raised 130 million dollars.
Around here
that's nothing, but in Chicago, that's a big
deal. 130
million dollars of startup funds out of the
Chicago and Bay area. Every single one of
them was for apps. Different kinds of apps.
So the kids
are really excited by entrepreneurship but
what your trying to say look at the
low barrier. Look at the big companies in
Chicago, Groupon, StubHub, GrubHub, sorry.
These are all companies that came out of the
same kind of
milieu. It's not a bad thing. I'm not speaking
against
that. The question is how do we excite those
other group
of kids? So, you know, if you look at University
graduate departments today, they're probably
50% foreign,
Chinese, Indian. And these days everyone's
going back to
China. Not as much India, but India also.
People are
going home. There are a lot of great opportunities
at home.
There's nothing wrong with that either. But
we're not
exciting our young kids in different ways.
Whether it's
just chemistry sets or better education programs.
I
think we need to do that and we don't do that
very much.
>>Male #4: I'm going to ask you a complementary
question for the
last one. I was a JBEI until a couple of months
ago and I saw ten post docs there for every
job there
was to be had. Once you finish your post doc.
What can
we do with our flood of post docs to turn
them into productive
researchers?
>>Isaacs: Send them to us. [chuckle] That
gets back to, it is a
complementary. Again, I'm not going to complain
here.
I'm going to make an observation. And it is
a true
observation. We don't make the high end stuff
so much
anymore, even the middle end stuff in this
country.
It's cheaper to do it elsewhere. We think
it's cheaper
it elsewhere. Not always. What would you tell
your post
doc if they choose to go into manufacturing
working on a
assembly line or actually working on an Intel
line for
example in China versus staying here and working
in Google.
So it's really hard to convince people when
we don't do
Stuff, when we don't make stuff in this country.
There's one path that says we'll only own
the
high end IP and we'll actually never make
stuff ever again.
People say we've given up manufacturing, so
you're never gonna get that same. The nine
post
docs that don't take the job at JBEI won't
end up doing stuff
here. They'll end up either teaching or they'll
go into
this business. And that's a problem. But if
we don't make
stuff, if we don't have a large set of jobs
out there
which are associated with the physical sciences,
the stuff I'm talking about, materials, then
I would
argue also that you wouldn't. There is a move
afoot to try and recapture manufacturing.
Whether we should be doing
that or not is a political question. I can
give you my opinion
which is we have to. But if you talk to half
of
Congress now doesn't believe that at all.
Maybe 51?of Congress doesn't believe that
at all that
restarting manufacturing here, advanced manufacturing.
I'm not talking about, you know, sweatshops
and clothing.
I'm talking about high end stuff like even
beyond
batteries, right? Solar photovoltaics. If
you talk to
AMAT, Applied Materials, just down the road
here, all of their plants are now in China,
in Asia, Singapore, China. So we're
not making stuff and if we're not going to
make the
high end stuff, if we cede that, then I have
a hard time saying what are those
nine post docs that don't get jobs at CalTech
or Berkeley
do.
[pause]
>>Male #5: Just back to this slide that you're
looking at the
superconducting out there a few generations
away. What
are some of the other properties you're looking
for in
those solid materials other than super connectivity,
battery storage capability.
>>Isaacs: That's a good question. So one I
mentioned which I
didn't articulate very much is, you want to,
more on
the biology side of materials, you want to
learn how
to, this is something that JBEI does actually,
you
want to learn how to co-opt. For example take
algae.
Algae is very intelligent at chewing grass
processing in
its gut through digestion enzymes, proteins
basically in the gut and creating things
like fuels. And so, Jay Keasling and his friends
at JBEI, you can probably talk about
this as well as I, have been very clever.
The problem
with that, let me give you an example. If
you take
algae and you can genetically engineer it.
Actually we know how to do that, genetically
engineer that. It's
still materials, but it's biology, biomaterials.
Genetically engineer the thing so it produces
let's say
ethanol or even a higher more sophisticated
version closer to biofuel like a diesel.
The problem is that typically that algae dies
because
it's like sitting in ethanol that kills life.
So JBEI's
been able to do, maybe you did this. I don't
know. It
engineers that algae so it doesn't die. It
can keep
excreting that stuff and live in that environment
so that it can start thinking about
producing more of it. So that's one thing
that would be
great to either co-opt the algae but of course
I said in the end it
still requires sunlight and you need huge
algae ponds to
do it and whether or not we have the area
to do it. The real question, the real challenge
is that can you make chemistries that mimic
life that can do the catalysis in
a beaker not in an algae farm? I don't know
whether you have an opinion. My opinion is
you need to
do that. One day you need to co-opt it from
a chemical point of
view so you can scale it. So a place like
the large
chemical companies like Dow, DuPont or Archer
Daniels Midland can
take very very dense cellulosic material and
make it into. So that's one
example. Photovoltaics are another example.
The
efficiency of today's photovoltaics the best
are about 7, 8% and you need 20, 30 even 40%
to make them useful. To do that we're not
just going to
use just a hunk of silicon. Silicon is actually
not very good for optics. Then the other semiconductors
like gallium arsenide are too
expensive. So you need to come up with some
kind of
interesting multidimensional nano material
that can
absorb the sunlight very, very efficiently
so it's black and
not green like a leaf. And then convert that
sunlight
into electron in a hole and basically charge
a battery with it or
send it onto a grid. We don't have that material
yet. A material that can
do that in a big way. I mean, I can go on
and on. These
are just examples. Everything that I can tell
you even
take nuclear energy actually. We're at the
end of life.
We have 104 reactors in this country. The
last one that
was built was somewhat just before Three Mile
Island
occurred. We haven't built one since then.
Look,
they're all at least 40 years old and some
of them are 60 years old, 55 anyway. So we're
extending their life. The materials in those
containment
vessels are embrittled. We have to learn a
lot about how to make materials that withstand
defects that are induced
by neutrons for example. So a lot of good
problems to
solve for the right reasons. We're only working
on some
of them; not on all of them. We're getting
beat out. I
kind of made that point. We're kind of getting
beat out
by a lot of countries now. It's not to say
we still don't have the
smartest guys in the world. I mean Stanford
itself, the physics department there has a
great group of people doing this work and
they're great. And they have a critical
mass, but it's only one of many places. If
you go to
China, there's tremendous number of activities
like that.
Any other questions?
>>Male #1: How close are we to something like
solar shingles
where you would just replace your regular
shingles by solar shingles and just?
>> Isaacs: At cost. There's actually a DOE
program out this called
SunShot. And the SunShot program it has I
think
it's by 20, I want to say 2017 or 18 they're
shooting to do
that basically. They're look at the cost.
I gave you 7 cents per
kilowatt hour unsubsidized. So to your point
before, if you ask me it's
somewhere between 2017 and 2050. If you'd
asked me what the ideal would be, I'd say
we
should have left Yucca Mountain open. We should
have
built out a couple of nuclear reactors to
compensate,
instead of growing coal which is what we're
doing, we
grow nuclear. And then by 2050, we'll solve
the solar
problem entirely. A slide I dropped out of
this talk, if you look at just the usable
land,
we have about 10,000 terawatts of sunlight.
And I told
you we only need about 15,000 terawatts on
the face of the
earth today. So again, there's a lot of headroom,
physicists headroom. So it just
seems to me that we have to get to that time.
I'm giving you a big range because there could
be
some eureka moments in the material development.
And if there
are then it will be accelerated. But the adoption
curve I
would say it's still probably, we'll see.
Germany is actually
the best producer of solar now, good, good
solar panels. They're very expensive.
China makes the most solar panels. They're
not as good,
but you could argue you could buy them today.
They're
still more expensive than pumping electricity
into a wire through your grid. by a lot. If
your willing to pay more, you could do it
today. But if you want to do it at cost, it's
probably ten years, five to
ten years.
>>Male #6: [inaudible]
>> Isaacs: I know, well here, maybe it's easier
here. For a while California had a
program it was a tax subsidy, right? For installing
solar panels on your roof. I forget the name
of the
program. It was okay. I think it's no longer.
I think
that's probably because--
>> Male #6: What I mean is [inaudible].
>>Isaacs: What I'm saying it's easier to make
the bar here in
California. So if you get below 31 cents,
maybe you'll
got enough people adopt it. So as an individual
house,
you can do it, but as California consumes
a large
fraction of the U.S.' power -- just count
the people.
And so, you still have a grid issue. And the
question is can you provide power in a city,
for example? And I don't know if San Francisco
is
not the best place to have solar. Right? So,
LA is probably better.
So you can subsidize the amount of electricity
you use,
but you're never going to be grid free, you're
not going to be off the grid in California.
Some houses can be
obviously, but on average, it's not going
to happen. So.
Any other questions? Well, thanks everybody
for
listening.
[Applause]